football star fever has been running
High all week in Saudi Arabia more than
2 million fans reportedly attempting to
get tickets to see Lionel Messi's
palisan German take on a Riyadh All-Star
team headlined by Cristiano Ronaldo I'm
very excited about the match I'm very
excited about to see Missy versus around
here the last match maybe between them
so I'm very very excited I was lucky
enough to see the game were treated to a
golf East
Messi who just last month LED Argentina
to World Cup glorian Qatar opened the
score in just minutes in SG and that's
the first goal
Ronaldo didn't waste any time responding
he won a penalty in pretty painful
fashion and he converted with ease for
his first goal since moving to Saudi
Arabia two levels for the Riyadh season
team
Ronaldo wasn't finished there the 37
year old scored a second showing the
Killer Instinct unless her fans will
hope to see on a regular basis
Ronaldo is equalized Ronaldo has
equalized in Riyadh
both Legends made their exits around the
hour mark their efforts warmly
appreciated by the sellout crowd
PSG going on to win a 5-4 on what was a
memorable night for the fans and a match
that was about more than just football
for Saudi Arabia
it's a major big events that are going
to be happening we hope that that uh
Saudi Arabia will have so one of them so
one of them will be the 2029 uh winter
agent Asian Winter Games you know which
is you know again an incredible thing to
look forward to in all this stuff but
also like Saudi Arabia is looking
hopefully to have the 2027 AFC Asian cup
you know and you know you know we hear
about like the World Cup bit you know
nothing official yet but obviously
that's something to keep an eye on this
match could turn out to be Messi and
Ronaldo's final encounter but what we've
seen from tonight there's plenty of
hunger for their legendary rivalry to
continue Sana hamush Al Jazeera Riyadh